[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur
TV 78 votre émission pour bien démarrer
la soirée dans les Yvelines avec au menu
de l'actualité et des infos pratiques et
des idées de sortie le 7 8 qui prend ces
quartiers aujourd'hui au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en Yvelines à
l'occasion de l'événement skit voici le
programme de ce mercredi 19 avril c'est
le rendez-vous dédié à l'innovation et
au talent de l'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelineskit se déroule
ce mercredi et demain au Vélodrome
national un événement mais de journée
aujourd'hui à ski cette talent qui était
dédié à l'emploi avec notamment plus de
10000 offres à saisir demain place à ski
innovation qui sera consacré aux
entreprises alors développement on en
parle avec nos invités et dans le 7 8
direction également le château de
Monte-Cristo au Port-Marly l'ancienne
demeure d'Alexandre Dumas métal honneur
dans une exposition les décors oubliés
et de sublime des cordes théâtre du 19e
19e siècle la plupart de ces maquettes
visibles ont servi de base pour de
nombreuses pièces jouées dans les plus
grands théâtres parisiens c'est à voir
jusqu'au 31
et puis elle n'attendent que vous 2500
poules recherches d'un foyer dans les
Yvelines si vous souhaitez en adopter
une entreprise du territoire vous
accompagne de A à Z tant qu'il orphelin
a créé à chacun sa poule pour répondre
aux besoins des professionnels mais
aussi et des particuliers zoom dans
cette édition
installer donc dans ce vélo drone
national de 50 ans en Yvelines à
l'occasion de ski Heat qui se déroule
aujourd'hui et demain sur place bonjour
Régine raleche de la rédaction de la TV
78 vous avez suivi justement pour TV 78
cette première journée skit talent qui
était dédié à l'emploi quel est le
premier bilan que vous pouvez faire de
cette journée qu'est-ce que vous avez pu
constater sur place alors c'était un
bilan plutôt positif puisqu'il y en
avait un peu de tout pour intéresser
tous les profils que ce soit des
étudiants des chercheurs d'emploi ou
même des personnes en reconversion
professionnelle on en dira un peu plus
tout à l'heure dans cette émission
également autour de moi sur ce plateau
du 7 8 au Vélodrome national des invités
il y a notamment Cathy cordani Régine si
vous voulez bien passer le micro le
plateau à notre invité Cathy cordani
bonsoir ou bonjour même si l'émission
sera diffusée ce soir donc pour vous
présenter vous êtes idote talent
acquisition à Thalès Thalès un groupe
qu'on ne présente plus mais qu'on va
quand même présenter groupe
d'électronique un spécialisé dans de
nombreux secteurs l'aéronautique le
sociale la défense la sécurité et des
locaux qui sont implantés aussi sur le
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines donc
bonjour à vous effectivement Thalès est
représenté aujourd'hui
à travers cet événement qui est
important sur le territoire au profit de
l'emploi et de la formation des jeunes
sur le territoire nous sommes ici
présents avec d'autres entreprises de la
tasse que force RH de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
rencontrer des candidates et des
candidats en recherche d'emploi et aussi
des jeunes qui recherchent des
formations en alternance ou bien des
stages nous avons pu les rencontrer dans
le cadre du job it à travers notre stand
au travers de l'innovation
tous les candidates et les candidats ont
pu s'exprimer présenter leur motivation
présenter leurs compétences lui garde
des postes ouverts sur notre site
Internet nous avons pu également animer
participer à l'animation de conférence
autour de recrutement innovants autour
de recrutement féminin dans les métiers
techniques était extrêmement intéressant
et on va parler bien sûr de votre
présence ici de l'intérêt de votre
présence tout à l'heure aussi dans le 7
8 en face de vous il y a un autre chef
d'entreprise qui est Kevin gif and vue
bonsoir alors vous vous êtes donc le
co-fondateur de la start-up RDI manager
une startup que vous avez co-fondé en
2021 vous êtes aujourd'hui bien sûr son
dirigeants et vous êtes installé à
Trappes alors juste pour présenter RDA
manager elle propose des outils
numériques de management de l'innovation
à travers une application qui est
directement destinée aux entreprises à
aussi des financeurs des universités
c'est bien ça tout à fait RD Manager
vous l'avez bien présenté une plateforme
numérique de management de l'innovation
à destination des entreprises innovantes
des universités laboratoires et des
financeurs de l'innovation nous avons
développé une approche originale de
gestion de projet basé sur un journal
collaboratif de projet en fait le cahier
de laboratoire de l'entreprise adaptée
aux enjeux d'innovation combien de
salariés pour RD manager on est cinq en
ce moment y compris moi et puis en ce
moment avec le job dating qu'on a pu
avoir aujourd'hui à l'occasion de la
Journée talent du ski hit on recherche
des stagiaires pour l'été des alternants
pour la saison prochaine et aussi des
CDI dans les domaines du développement
numérique et puis du développement
technique au commercial regardez manager
juste pour le préciser a été nommé parmi
les cités 2022 les plus innovants donc
on parlait d'innovation voici une
start-up innovante sur le territoire et
de 50 ans en Yvelines il y aura aussi un
autre invité qui sera avec nous tout à
l'heure c'est Nicolas Dainville
vice-président de l'agglomération de 50
ans Yvelines et déléguer à l'emploi la
formation professionnelle et à
l'apprentissage quels sont les objectifs
de cet événement quelle est la situation
en matière d'emploi à 50 ans en Yvelines
quelles sont les opportunités sur le
territoire on lui posera toutes ces
questions et à l'instar journaliste de
tv78 il y a également une autre
journaliste qui est avec nous d'ores et
déjà en plateau c'est Mathilde Franco
bonsoir bonsoir Grégory on va voir ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité du
jour dans les Yvelines il y aura
également Céline Charles tout à l'heure
qui nous présentera également les les
films à l'affiche de ce mercredi au
cinéma un jour de sortie au cinéma elle
nous fera elle nous livrera sa sélection
des films à ne pas manquer cette semaine
voici le programme de ce 7 8 et juste
avant de le dérouler on va jeter un
petit coup d'oeil aux prévisions météo
de demain
[Musique]
ce sera toujours frais demain matin dans
les Yvelines mais avec tout de même du
soleil annoncé dans la matinée sur le
territoire il devrait faire 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et dans les secteurs de
Versailles et de 50 ans en Yvelines 6° à
Houdan et Rambouillet dans l'après-midi
les conditions météo se dégradent avec
de la pluie prévue dans le département
seul le secteur de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines pourrait être épargné côté
température compter entre 10 et 12
degrés et demain jeudi 20 avril elle
nous fêterons les odettes le point à
présent sur l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Mathilde Franco on
commence ces informations du jour par
une annonce une annonce qui nous a été
faite dans l'après-midi oui selon nos
confrères de RMC Sport et 7 8 actus
Charline Avenel la rectrice de
l'académie de Versailles pourraient
devenir la prochaine directrice générale
de la Fédération Française de Football
elle ferait partie des derniers
candidats en liste après le licenciement
de Florence Hardouin face à elle
Jean-François Villotte ancien directeur
général de la Fédération de tennis et
Erwan Leprévost actuel directeur des
relations institutionnelles à la
Fédération de football
issue de la même promotion à l'ENA
qu'Emmanuel Macron le profil de Charline
Avenel Perret beaucoup en interne
toujours selon RMC Sport contactez par
nos soins l'académie de Versailles ne
confirme pas cette information sans
toutefois la démentir on poursuit ces
informations du jour avec cette nouvelle
journée de grève annoncée demain contre
la réforme des retraites ça risque
d'être compliqué ou pas pour les
utilisateurs dans les de transport
effectivement malgré la promulgation de
la loi sur les retraites les quatre
syndicats de la SNCF poursuivent la
mobilisation et annonce une journée
d'expression de la colère cheminotes
plusieurs perturbations sont donc à
prévoir dans les Yvelines concernant les
lignes uj et l prévoyaient de trains sur
3 sur la ligne N comptait trois trains
sur 4 côté RER le trafic sera également
légèrement perturbé pour les usagers du
RER A et B la circulation sera à quasi
normale cependant pour le RER C il
faudra compter deux trains sur 3 la CGT
appelle à deux nouvelles journées de
grève le vendredi 28 avril et le lundi
1er mai à l'occasion de la fête du
travail sur les sites de la RATP ratp.fr
transilien.com pour avoir toutes les
informations en temps réel sur vos
conditions de circulation 10% Mathilde
c'est le chiffre du jour pourquoi 10%
Grégory c'est le nombre d'habitants qui
n'ont pas de médecins généralistes dans
le secteur de Rambouillet pour lutter
contre la désertification médicale dans
le sud le collectif pour l'hôpital et la
santé publique organise une nouvelle
réunion demain soir à 20h il souhaite la
création d'un centre de santé publique à
Rambouillet ses établissements
regroupent différents professionnels de
santé qui exercent sous un statut de
salarié et non pas de libéraux comme on
peut comme c'est le cas dans certaines
maisons de santé au-delà de la pénurie
des médecins le collectif s'inquiète
également de l'avenir de l'hôpital de
Rambouillet selon eux une cinquantaine
de soignants ont quitté l'établissement
après la crise du covid 19 on parle à
présent d'un nouveau lieu dédié à
l'enfance qui va ouvrir dans les
Yvelines le domaine de la frrosardière à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux est en cours
d'acquisition par le département des
Yvelines propriétés des pompiers de
Paris le lieu à vocation de devenir un
village d'enfant il accueillera ainsi
des jeunes de 0 à 21 ans entouré par des
éducateurs familiaux ils pourront ainsi
se reconstruire et trouver un
environnement familial stable Alexandra
Rosetti la mère de la commune souhaite
que ce site apporte un poudre de vie qui
ressemble plus possible à une famille au
total 60 enfants pourront être hébergés
la construction devrait débuter en 2024
on termine par une conférence ça se
passe demain du côté de la Bibliothèque
Universitaire de l'université Versailles
50 ans en Yvelines à Guyancourt oui
cette conférence débat aura lieu demain
soir de 17h à 19h à l'auditorium de la
bibliothèque universitaire elle sera
animée par les deux auteurs du livre des
hommes des femmes no liberté Nathalie
Wolf maître de conférence à l'Université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
et Laura elmaki professeur à Sciences Po
dans cette conférence il sera question
du droit à la justice à la dignité
humaine à l'intimité en passant par le
droit à un environnement sain et à la
liberté d'expression alors que de
nouveaux droits s'écrivent chaque jour
les écrivains se questionnent sur la
fragilité de certains droits à qui par
le passé ce sera donc demain merci
beaucoup à Mathilde pour toutes ces
actualités et si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous voyez une actualité une
information qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7 8 news
[Musique]
le 7 8 depuis le vélo drone national de
50 ans en Yvelines à l'occasion de
l'événement à ski dédié aux innovations
et au talents et on va revenir sur cette
première journée qui était consacrée à
l'emploi avec vous Régine rallès une
journée qui était riche en opportunité
de business oui c'est ça il vous le
disiez d'ailleurs tout à l'heure pour
cette journée dédiée au talent plus de
10000 offres étaient à pourvoir et
justement tout au long de la journée un
job dating était organisé plus de 700
candidats ont passé des entretiens d'une
vingtaine de minutes mais attention les
entreprises elles doivent aussi séduire
car ils ont des besoins en termes de
recrutement et c'est pour ça que
certaines d'entre elles étaient
présentes dans la partie innovite pour
présenter leurs activités et leurs
innovations une journée pour les
salariés mais aussi tourner vers les
entrepreneurs oui c'était d'ailleurs
l'opportunité pour eux d'échanger avec
des experts de la création d'entreprises
et
de la conseil notamment sur des
questions de financement d'aspects
juridique ou encore sur les étapes de
création d'une entreprise mais le plus
de cette journée c'est peut-être aussi
cette partie qui a été dédiée aux femmes
dans le numérique on le sait les femmes
sont sous représentées dans le domaine
et ne représentent d'ailleurs que 10 %
elles ne sont que 10 % à occuper des
fonctions techniques et pour en parler
ce matin il y avait d'ailleurs des
conférences et des prises de parole dans
la partie pichit j'ai d'ailleurs
rencontré l'une des participantes Émilie
saussa qu'elle travaille à Orano un
acteur majeur du nucléaire on l'écoute
aujourd'hui il est quand même encore
difficile d'attirer les femmes dans les
milieux de l'industrie et de la
technique donc vraiment il est important
pour moi de témoigner que ces
carrières-là elles sont passionnantes
qui a beaucoup d'opportunités et qu'il
faut surtout pas se brider et ne pas
hésiter à rejoindre ce monde là qui est
un univers où on peut vraiment grandir
et s'épanouir et vivre des supers
expériences
et demain ce sera la journée dédiée aux
innovations on y reviendra plus en plus
dans une nouvelle chronique merci Régine
bien sûr demain vous revenez sur ce
plateau un plateau qui sera de nouveau
installé ici au Vélodrome national de 50
ans en Yvelines à l'occasion de la
deuxième journée de ce qui est un nouvel
invité qui nous a rejoint en plateau
c'est Nicolas Dainville bonjour bonjour
vice-président de 51 en Yvelines vous
êtes en charge de l'Emploi de la
Formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage une journée alors qui
n'est pas forcément nouvelle c'est cet
événement n'est pas nouveau il faut le
préciser puisque ce qui regroupe en fait
deux événements qui existaient déjà sur
le territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines Sky
Business Day et ski emploie en piste
concrètement pourquoi réunir les deux
pourquoi proposer un événement unique
ici au Vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Yvelines bah écoutez premièrement parce
que ça ça a du sens deuxièmement parce
que ça permet de faire aussi des
économies d'échelle c'est vrai que les
collectivités locales comme les
entreprises comme tous les ménages font
face effectivement à une inflation font
face à à vraiment des difficultés aussi
avec le explosion des coûts et donc il
faut qu'on fasse attention et donc à la
fois ça a du sens et en plus ça permet
d'avoir deux beaux événements pour le
prix d'un oui puisque il y a une journée
emploi demain une journée dédiée
directement aux entreprises on est plus
sur du B2B et demain business to
business exactement événement autour des
talents donc au plus tôt de l'emploi
aujourd'hui et puis demain le ski
business d pour rapprocher les
entreprises entre elles pour essayer de
leur permettre de faciliter les échanges
que les gros et les petits les startups
puissent mieux travailler ensemble dans
le genre d'événement au-delà de
l'organisation c'est ça c'est 50 ans
divine est un facilitateur des
rencontres entre les salariés les
entreprises les jeunes diplômés parfois
même les étudiants qui sont encore en
cours en ce moment bah écoutez le
président de 50 ans dit toujours que
Saint-Quentin c'est un territoire béni
des dieux on a les plus belles boîtes du
monde alors on parle souvent des grands
groupes Airbus Thalès Renault 17000
entreprises 17000 entreprises on a aussi
des PME extraordinaires RDI manager des
start-ups dans notre
et donc tout ce tissu entrepreneurial
effectivement faut mettre du liant et
ces événements sont une occasion de les
réunir justement faire réagir nos
invités et notamment Cathy cordani pour
pour Thalès c'est important que une
agglomération soit aussi pour faciliter
ces échanges qui peut-être parfois sont
difficiles de réunir salarié et
l'entreprise directement de les faire
matcher tout de suite tout à fait
l'objet de cette journée était de
promouvoir un événement en termes de
recrutement innovant ce qui innovant
c'est de travailler ensemble sur 50 ans
en Yvelines de regrouper nos forces
vives en termes de recrutement pour
rencontrer les candidates et les
candidats sur le site d'Élancourt que je
représente aujourd'hui nous avons plus
de 600 postes en CDI pour voir cette
année plus de 100 postes d'apprentissage
plus de 200 pose de stagiaires dans quel
secteur de métier nous devons recruter
essentiellement dans les métiers
techniques en ivvq en ingénierie système
d'études en logiciel mais également des
postes en industrie de monteurs de
techniciens intégration Kevin justement
pour la société RDI manager on vous est
croisé notamment sur le Big tour qui est
organisé ici même au vélo de 50 ans en
Yvelines par BPI France vous êtes
preneur de ce genre d'événements
justement pour qui est un côté facilité
d'aller rencontrer vous peut-être vos
futurs collaborateurs absolument
absolument ce type d'événement ça nous
permet ça nous donne la possibilité de
rencontrer et des talents et des
entreprises innovantes et des potentiels
clients et nous sommes vraiment preneurs
de cette approche et ces solutions de
facilitation que le territoire nous
offre le Big too nous avons recruté déjà
au big to et nous continuons et là nous
espérons à retrouver de nouveaux talents
et demain faire du business alors le
vice-président Nicolas parlait de
l'économie d'échelle effectivement en
une action on fait deux opérations des
talents et du recrutement et ça c'est
génial et quels sont vos besoins en
matière recrutement aujourd'hui à
Matthieu de recrutement on recherche des
développeurs dans le numérique
développeur full steak développeur web
des web aussi et aussi des stagiaires
côté technique ou commercial franchement
on a besoin de d'alternant des CDI et
des stagiaires pour la saison d'été qui
va commencer la bientôt et les
rencontres étaient bonnes aujourd'hui
elles ont été plutôt agréables
agréablement surpris d'ailleurs et on
espère que ça continue comme ça demain
également intéressant pour Thalès les
rencontres que vous avez pu faire
aujourd'hui sur place tout à fait nous
avons rencontré plus de 500 pardon 50
candidats 500 peut-être un jour mais 50
candidats qui se sont portés intéressés
ils veulent gardent nos offres de postes
ouvertes sur le site d'Élancourt 5
filières d'excellence mise en avant
aujourd'hui Nicolas Darville également
demain on parle de l'aéronautique de la
mobilité du numérique de la santé de
l'énergie avec beaucoup de possibilités
à 50 ans de nuit on disait tout à
l'heure à 17000 entreprises des grands
groupes des PME des startups il y a
beaucoup d'opportunités oui
je vais vous parler des 70 contacts
c'est vrai qu'on a eu 1000 visiteurs
aujourd'hui et ça continue d'arriver et
puis on a eu des entreprises qui ont pu
aussi avoir des rendez-vous vraiment
ciblés préprogrammés à l'avance donc
près de 70 entreprises qui ont répondu
présent sur ce dispositif assez innovant
on a effectivement des métiers
d'excellence qui parfois peine à
recruter mais qui est du numérique on
recherche effectivement des des
compétences des expertises notamment
dans la cybersécurité mais tous les
secteurs que vous avez cités
aéronautique défense santé numérique
transport recherche effectivement des
talents là il y avait 10 000 offres
d'emploi aujourd'hui il y a également le
site Ski emploi au singulier.fr
plateforme on peut retrouver des offres
d'emploi il y a je crois 36 000 inscrits
sur ce site qui est la plateforme
d'entrée pour rapprocher nos demandeurs
d'emploi et nos recruteurs et donc faut
vraiment pas hésiter à solliciter ce
site internet pour rapprocher donc
l'offre et la demande et vous le des
besoins en recrutement d'ailleurs à 50
ans en Yvelines il y a un chiffre à
ressortir c'est que 70% des profils
recherchés sur le territoire sont pour
des postes qualifiés à un niveau bac au
moins ou supérieur justement oui c'est
vrai qu'on a ces belles entreprises mais
qui sont des entreprises à forte valeur
ajoutée qui recherche effectivement des
talents qualifiés effectivement 70%
plutôt bac à bac + 2 et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut laisser personne au bord du
chemin donc là c'est un événement autour
on va dire plutôt des talents qualifiés
mais il y aura d'autres événements pour
des talents qui n'ont pas forcément les
qualifications académiques mais qui ont
ce qu'on appelle les soft skills qui ont
une motivation extraordinaire une une
d'autres compétence à apporter à
l'entreprise donc ça on aura d'autres
événements et notamment autour des Jeux
Olympiques puisque les JO ça vous aura
pas échappé à transition Nicolas
justement il y a corner qui est dédié
aux JO sur cet événement skit on le sait
l'agglomération va accueillir plusieurs
épreuves sur ce vélo de route nationale
de 50 ans Yvelines le Stadium de BM
juste à côté le Golf National à
Guyancourt et la colline à Élancourt là
pareil de nombreuses opportunités ça
ouvre de nouvelles perspective bah
écoutez oui on recherchait énormément
dans l'hôtellerie la restauration qui
est un petit peu dévastée avec le covid
donc là il y a des postes vraiment très
important à offrir les métiers des
transports chauffeurs conducteurs il y a
un manque criant pour notamment
aujourd'hui mais aussi pour accueillir
les les milliers milliers de visiteurs
qui viendront en France à Paris en 2024
et puis les métiers la sécurité je crois
que le chiffre évoqué autour de 20 000
c'est-à-dire 20000 postes à pourvoir ce
qui est énorme et donc l'État a mis en
place des dispositifs pour aussi
permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent de
prêter ma force avec des qualifications
donc pour les JO en tant qu'entreprise
implantée directement sur le territoire
vous les voyez comment c'est Jo comme
une nouvelle opportunité où il y a un
certain engouement aussi à voir cet
événement olympique arriver d'ici un peu
plus d'un an maintenant tout à fait
c'est une fierté pour nos salariés
d'être sur un territoire qui accueille
une réelle fierté ça également un
élément d'attractivité sur notre
territoire
et c'est une possibilité pour nous de se
faire voir de voir de voir mettre en
évidence le territoire et puis d'être
parti prenant de ce bel événement qui
réunit tout le monde dans l'espoir et la
joie en économie c'est aussi l'occasion
de faire un point sur l'emploi plus
généralement à 50 ans en Yvelines ce
chiffre 35000 embauches au troisième
trimestre 2022 à 50 ans en nuit on peut
le dire l'emploi se porte plutôt bien
dans l'agglomération après des moments
de crise covid-19 la guerre en Ukraine
aussi l'an passé oui c'est vrai qu'on a
un département les Yvelines qui
malheureusement n'a pas retrouvé son
niveau d'avant crise 2008 avec une
désindustrialisation qui est quand même
criante mais heureusement à 50 ans en
Yvelines on est un îlot avec beaucoup de
services qui permet de très bien s'en
sortir et donc effectivement
on a un dynamisme qui nous caractérise
toutes les entreprises sont marquées de
voilà par cette crise qui les frappe de
plein fouet comme les collectivités
comme les ménages avec le le coût des
énergies qui explosent donc ça
effectivement ça freine un petit peu
l'activité mais on a quand même un
dynamisme qui caractérise vraiment 50
ans est-ce que c'est pas plus facile en
ayant sur ce territoire un réservoir de
talent il y a un pôle universitaire avec
l'université Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines membre fondateur de
l'université Paris-Saclay des écoles
aussi de renom ça facilite les choses
aussi après derrière pour le recrutement
on posera la question aussi aux
entreprises qui sont représentées ici
écoutez oui on a effectivement l'UVSQ
qui fait partie maintenant donc de
l'université paris-saclet qui fait
partie des meilleurs universités en
France et dans le monde il y a un anneau
satellite qui a été envoyé plusieurs
reports mais il a bien été envoyé
dans l'espace pour surveiller les enjeux
du climat et il a été conçu vraiment par
les équipes de de Saint-Quentin donc on
a vraiment un territoire d'excellence
les écoles du numérique aussi qui permet
de former sur cette compétence qui est
très demandée et puis plein d'autres
écoles d'enseignement supérieur qui
permettent d'offrir aux yvelinois mais
au 56 mois vraiment l'excellence au pied
au pied de chez eux vous le voyez comme
une chance ce réservoir de talent
directement disponible sur sur ce
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines oui
tout à fait le marché du travail est
actuellement extrêmement tendu nous
avons 150 ans en Yvelines beaucoup
d'offres dans le foie pour voir ton CDI
qu'on alternance ou bien en stage c'est
une opportunité d'avoir ces écoles sur
place pour former nos jeunes à nos
métiers et à nos produits dans vos
collaborateurs est-ce qu'il y a des dans
vos salariés des des étudiants d'anciens
étudiants qui se sont formés sur ce
territoire ah oui nous nous appuyons
beaucoup à RD managers le territoire
asensia Business School l'Université des
50 ans en Yvelines et les autres
structures de formation du territoire on
s'appuie en priorité sur eux parce qu'on
sait que c'est la proximité c'est fiable
et c'est du durable et c'est c'est du
tout bénef quoi alors pour justement
connaître ces opportunité une emploi
Nicolas David vous le disiez il y a ce
portail Sky emploi.fr ce qui emploie.fr
il y a aussi de nouvelles manières de
recruter l'agglomération organisée
justement il y a quelques mois des un
street recruti ça s'est passé pendant
deux jours à l'espace Saint-Quentin le
centre commercial à 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est quoi le concept du street
recruting mais écoutez c'est vrai que
plutôt que d'attendre souvent
passivement que les les les les les ce
qui recherchent un emploi viennent à
nous on a décidé d'inverser la tendance
et donc d'aller vers d'aller sur le
terrain de parler effectivement emploi
de manière différente et c'est vrai
qu'on a fait donc du street recruting
avec mon excellent accent anglais tout
le monde aura compris
l'aventure notamment à la gare au centre
commercial et il y a eu plusieurs
milliers 3000 prises voilà contact
contact très utile et en plus dans d'une
manière originale c'était pas dans une
salle derrière un bureau et ça permet
aussi d'évaluer d'autres d'autres traits
de personnalités des futurs candidats et
sur le terrain il y avait presque force
RH ça a été évoqué durant les interviews
c'est quoi aussi cette tasse que force
RH un outil supplémentaire un bel outil
d'ailleurs Thalès en fait partie on est
très fiers de de les avoir effectivement
on réunit les DRH d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises pour aussi renforcer le
sentiment d'appartenance leur faire
mieux découvrir le territoire donc on a
fait des des visites de territoire
puisque une entreprise qui connaît ce
beau territoire qui l'apprécie sera
implanté d'autant plus durablement et
puis ça permet pour nous de mieux
comprendre aussi les besoins de
recrutement et de mieux y répondre mieux
y répondre avec notamment en adaptant
l'offre pour ça qu'on a créé les écoles
du numérique donc on a labellisé des
écoles du numérique parce que justement
les entreprises du territoire nous
faisaient vraiment part de leur grande
difficulté de recrutement des profils
dans secteur toute dernière question
donc la première journée qui va se
terminer dédier à l'emploi demain on le
disait une journée dédiée aux
entreprises qui s'appelle cette fois-ci
skit innovation là les entreprises
concrètement juste pour repréciser vont
pouvoir se rencontrer faire du business
voilà donc là on est sous l'impulsion
d'Alexandra Rosetti qui est la
vice-présidente au développement
économique il sera notre invité demain
dans le 7 8 et qui du coup effectivement
avec tous les services que je tiens à
remercier parce qu'ils ont fait un très
gros boulot pour organiser ces là tout
roule c'est magnifique c'est le cas de
le dire mais c'est comme un boulot
énorme derrière et donc demain c'est
vraiment pour rapprocher les entreprises
entre elles donc là on est plus trop
dans une logique de recrutement mais
plutôt de collaboration de partenariats
entre entreprises Kevin gifen je vous y
serez demain à ce site innovation demain
nous y serons pour le skate innovation
et l'innovation j'ai envie de dire ça a
commencé déjà aujourd'hui avec
l'approche innovante de recrutement que
51 met en place avec le vice-présor
Nicolas aujourd'hui on a fait des speed
dating on a fait adopter un Beauce on
fait aussi du street recruting on fait
plein d'autres approches que ce soit qui
et ça c'est vraiment l'ADN d'innovation
de 50 ans en Yvelines et aujourd'hui et
demain on y sera et ça sera à 200% des
pieds d'une entreprise démonstration
également il y avait ce job dating
également au programme pareil pour
Thalès sera présent demain pour ce qui
est innovation la suite de ce qui est
tout à fait mes collègues seront
présents que je retiens de cette journée
Nicolas la bien dit il y a deux mots
clés il faut aller vers les candidats il
faut donner envie aux comptes nous
rejoindre allez vers donner envie voilà
les mettre aux clés et bien merci à tous
les trois d'être venu à en parler en
plateau merci également à reginal de la
rédaction tv78 voilà ce qu'on le pouvait
vous dire aujourd'hui sur cet événement
ce qui est événement consacré aux
innovations au talent du territoire de
50 ans en Yvelines ça se passe
aujourd'hui et demain dans le vélo drone
national de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
Première journée ce mercredi ce mercredi
dédié à l'emploi demain ce sera donc
dédié aux entreprises place à skit
innovation je vous le disais consacré
aux entreprises et alors développement
on en parlera demain ici même sur ce
plateau du 7 8 avec de nouveaux invités
la suite du 7 8 tout de suite
du Vélodrome national nous allons
prendre la direction de Port-Marly à
travers l'expo les décors oubliés le
château de Monte-Cristo rend hommage aux
artistes qui ont conçu les plus beaux
décors du théâtre du à 19e siècle la
plupart des maquettes exposées ont servi
de base pour de nombreuses pièces jouées
dans les plus grands théâtres parisiens
comme l'opéra La Comédie Française
également a découvertes avec Mathilde
Franco et Julien Leroy
c'est bon vous pouvez partir et
merveilleux les visiteurs replongent
dans les décors de pièces de théâtre
datant du 19e siècle forêt jardin
bâtiment d'époque ou encore scène de
bataille l'exposition les décors oubliés
au château de Monte-Cristo regroupe une
dizaine de maquettes rarement montré au
grand public les 10 maquettes qui sont
présentées ici à Monte-Cristo il y en a
deux qui sont des décors de théâtre de
d'Alexandre Dumas il y a la tour de
naine et la dame de Montsoreau ça aurait
été important pour Alexandre Dumas de
savoir que
bien après tous ces hommes qui ont
construit le théâtre et bien on leur
rend dommage parce que c'est un travail
minutieux de précision et ça fait partie
de notre patrimoine aujourd'hui ces
décors de théâtre sont magnifiques ils
sont peints à l'encre de Chine ou la vie
sera c'est très beau don Juan la poule
aux odeurs ou encore Jeanne d'Arc des
pièces de théâtre qui résonnent leur
décor sont précieusement dans cette
exposition l'objectif les remettre en
lumière mais aussi rendre hommage au
savoir-faire de ses peintres et
décorateurs ces maquettes étaient
construites sur une échelle de 300e
et le travail des peintres par la suite
une fois que la maquette est acceptée
par le directeur du théâtre le travail
des peintres était de
reconstituer de confectionner les vrais
décors et donc il reportait c'était un
travail aux carreau donc il reportait
les trois centimètres pour 1 m sur de
grandes toiles tous ces décors viennent
d'une collection privée pour les admirer
vous avez jusqu'au 31 mai
[Musique]
un reportage sur le château de
Monte-Cristo ancienne demeure de Régine
Céline Charles aussi qui nous a rejoint
au plateau bonjour Céline bonsoir
bonsoir Alexandre Dumas tout à fait
célèbre auteur des Trois Mousquetaires
d'ailleurs la première partie de
l'adaptation de Martin Bourbon est
toujours à l'affiche au cinéma mais de
nouveau film sont bien sûr à l'affiche
des mercredis des ce mercredi jour de
sortie dans les salles obscures
justement comme chaque mercredi Céline
vous nous livrez votre sélection des
films à ne pas manquer au cinéma cette
semaine et pour débuter d'ailleurs on va
parler d'un film historique et tout à
fait Grégory la conférence du
réalisateur allemand Matic guechonnec
revient sur l'une des pages les plus
sombres de l'histoire le film
reconstitue les minutes de la conférence
one see qui s'est tenu en janvier 1942
qui avait pour but d'organiser la
solution finale du régime nazi ce
jour-là à une quinzaine de dignitaires
du Troisième Reich se retrouve dans une
villa près de Berlin à la demande de
reinhardrich numéro 2 de la Gestapo s'en
suit deux heures de débat et de jeux de
pouvoir pour a décidé du sort de plus de
11 millions de personnes basées sur le
vrai procès-verbal des échanges des
échanges c'est huit clos filmés à la
manière d'un documentaire terrifie de
par la banalité et la froideur des
discussions sur un sujet pourtant
glaçant regardé
[Musique]
mais ouvre ces personnages
plus léger à présent Céline le retour
sur grand écran d'un duo parmi les plus
mythiques du cinéma français tout à fait
vous connaissez le dicton on prend les
mêmes et on recommence et bien c'est le
cas ici avec Dany Boon et kan Merah dont
les a vu dans Bienvenue chez les Ch'tis
ou encore super condriaque le duo fait
son retour dans la nouvelle comédie de
Dany Boon la vie pour de vrai dans ce
film Dany Boon et un quart de trident un
quinquagénaire très candide qui a
toujours vécu loin du monde puisque son
père était directeur du club med au
Mexique dans lequel il a grandi il
décide soudainement de partir pour Paris
pour tenter d'y retrouver violette une
fille dont il est tombé amoureux à l'âge
de 8 ans dans sa quête il va demander
l'aide de son demi-frère récemment
découvert interprété par Kad Merad ce
dernier pas très heureux de devoir
supporter ce personnage encombrant va
supplier une de ses conquêtes jouées par
Charlotte Gainsbourg de se faire passer
pour Violette regarder
[Musique]
ça fait si longtemps
oui pardon c'est l'émotion de le revoir
et on termine Céline avec un film qui va
en faire frissonner plus d'un et oui
autour du plateau vous connaissez
peut-être Evil Dead je ne sais pas
très fun de ce genre de film je connais
pas un très bon film de Sam Rémy qui a
d'ailleurs révolutionné le cinéma
d'horreur en 1981 cette semaine je vous
propose Evil Dead Reyes cette fois-ci
réalisé par lick chronin même si ça me
Rémy en est le producteur ce nouveau
chapitre de la saga nous propose une
intrigue différente et un nouveau
casting mais l'univers est sensiblement
le même ils n'ont plonge dans la nuit
mouvementée d'une mère de ses enfants et
de leur tente pris au piège par une
force démoniaque libérée par un livre
des morts le fameux néronomicon un huit
clos qui se déroule dans un immeuble
délabré en plein milieu de Los Angeles
attention aux plus sensible régime par
exemple ce film gore s'adresse plutôt
aux amateurs d'horreur et de sensations
fortes merci Céline pour cette sélection
pour moi ce sera pas le film d'horreur
plutôt la conférence un film historique
pour vous régénérer pour aller avec le
printemps ça sera la vie pour de vrai
une sélection parmi la sélection que
vous nous avez livrées
une très bonne reconstitution historique
merci pour ces idées de sortie au cinéma
des films à voir des aujourd'hui dans
les salles obscures chaque mercredi
également dans le 7 8 une spécialiste ou
un spécialiste du cinéma prend les
commandes pour vous conseiller un film à
découvrir ou redécouvrir si je vous dis
la vie des autres est-ce que ça vous
évoque quelque chose Régine
quelque chose mais je suis pas sûr bon
Céline pareil c'est un film qui est
sorti en 2006 film allemand réalisé par
Florian heinekel vandoor Smart et c'est
le couple le coup de cœur du réalisateur
yvelinois Thomas Salazar
[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
mon coup de coeur il s'agit du film la
vie des autres de Florian Heckel
vandenersmark qui est sorti en 2007 il
s'agit d'un film allemand et qui parle
au final de l'Allemagne parce que ça
parle vraiment de cette époque de la
guerre froide ou l'Allemagne était
séparée en deux l'Allemagne de l'Est et
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest sachant que
l'Allemagne de l'Est était une dictature
à l'époque donc ce film en fait se passe
dans cette Allemagne de l'Est dans cette
dictature qui raconte l'histoire d'un
auteur de théâtre qui va être surveillé
par la Stasi la Stasi c'était le
ministère qui qui est en charge de
surveiller un peu ce qu'on prenait pour
des espions à l'époque ou qui ne suivait
pas bien cette les règles de l'Allemagne
de l'Est under
[Musique]
et donc en fait le film au début on va
croire que ce film est sûr cet auteur de
théâtre mais en fait non il est sur le
personnage le policier qui surveille
donc qui est juste au-dessus de son
appartement avec son casque et qui
surveille cette hauteur de théâtre qui
va se rendre compte en fait petit à
petit qui vit dans une dictature et
qu'il est au service du d'une dictature
et que ce qui fait cette espionnage sur
ce sur cet auteur de date n'est pas
normal je vous conseille vraiment ce
film parce qu'il est il est bouleversant
le jeu des acteurs et et incroyable
regardez là en VO bien sûr un sous-titré
en français il a eu d'ailleurs l'Oscar
2007 meilleur film étranger voilà je
vous conseille la vie des autres de
Florian heinekel von denersmark
[Musique]
on continue dans le 7 8 à vous donner
d'autres envies de sortir d'autres idées
pour sortir dans les Yvelines et cette
fois-ci on va du côté de Chevreuse après
une première exposition à son ouverture
le musée Grataloup de Chevreuse meta
nouveau en avant le travail de ce
peintre les arbres m'ont dit le nom de
cette exposition présente une quinzaine
d'oeuvres de Grataloup autour des arbres
et de la nature on va regarder tout de
suite votre reportage c'est inchallah
tous les arbres des tableaux ont des
histoires à te raconter
si tu m'écoutes très attentivement je te
dirai tout leur secret
ils existent depuis des millions
d'années les arbres ont une être les
hommes et la civilisation des vieux
sages témoins muets de notre histoire
qui ont inspiré le peintre grataloups
tout au long de sa vie que savons-nous
sur eux l'exposition les arbres m'ont
dit au musée Grataloup de Chevreuse
apporte quelques éléments de réponse
j'ai imaginez en fait tout un parcours
où les en faisant parler les arbres et
pour qui nous explique combien ils sont
importants pour nous pour vivre c'était
le peintre de la nature grâce à l'eau il
peignait bien sûr avant tout la nature
et dans la nature et ce qui est de plus
important ce sont les arbres c'est toute
cette histoire à travers ses siècles de
vie finalement parce que nous humains on
est tout petit à côté des arbres une
exposition didactique qui sensibilise
sur le besoin
urgent de préserver notre planète et sa
biodiversité elle a été pensée lors de
multiples incendies qui ont ravagé les
forêts lors de l'été 2022 j'étais au
bord de l'océan et autour de moi les
sapins brûlaient et j'étais absolument
effrayée par ses sapins qui brûlaient et
j'ai pensé à cette qui avait fait
Grataloup parce que Grataloup c'est un
précurseur en fait c'est des au-delà du
Précurseur c'était quelqu'un qui sentait
toujours les choses arriver avant
qu'elle n'arrives j'ai pensé que il
fallait faire quelque chose pour les
arbres c'était une sorte de plaidoyer
pour les arbres c'était
qu'on prenne conscience que ils sont la
vie et la vie bien avant nous donc bon
là je crois que ça parle d'elle-même
vous voyez donc la forêt avant le feu et
la forêt au moment du feu et pour se
ressourcer le musée ne propose pas de
câliner un arbre comme la silvothérapie
le suggère mais elle accueille en
revanche dans ses jardins les oeuvres de
l'artiste peintre énergéticienne c'était
la brillant j'exposition en fait les 7
couleurs des sept chakras que j'ai
réalisé sur du bois d'azobe qui a un
bois exotique qui est utilisé pour la
construction des planches de Deauville
chaque chakra à une spécificité en fait
et moi je la retranscris par les
spirales que je réalise le but c'est que
les gens qui viennent visiter cette
exposition bien prennent du temps pour
se placer devant chaque œuvre et
reçoivent en fait un soin un soin
d'amour et un soin qui correspond à la
couleur qu'ils ont envie de voir
l'exposition est ouverte jusqu'au 5
novembre 2023 elle propose aux plus
jeunes un podcast adapté pendant la
visite de quoi on apprendrent plus sur
ces grands végétaux en plein cœur du
parc national de la Vallée de Chevreuse
[Musique]
dites nous en plus c'est ce qu'il y a un
argument à mettre en avant pour donner
envie à nos téléspectateurs les
spectateurs également présent à ce vélo
de Rome dans ce vélo Drôme national
d'aller voir cette exposition déjà il
faut savoir que le musée Grataloup c'est
une histoire de famille parce que le
peintre est décédé il y a un peu plus
d'un an mais c'est ça son épouse Milena
qui reprend un petit peu qui prend les
reines de ce musée et donc elle écrit
toutes les légendes elles-mêmes
descriptive en dessous des œuvres et
elle les adapte aux enfants comme aux
adultes en fait il est vraiment elle se
passionne pour ça et c'est aussi la
soeur de Milena qui fait le son et
lumière donc pour être accompagné un
petit peu d'un podcast son et lumière
donc voilà c'est vraiment une une
exposition immersive alors pour refermer
cette émission on va regarder un autre
de vos reportages décidément une
deuxième partie entièrement consacrée à
vos travaux Céline Charles une actu
quelque peu insolite on peut adopter une
poule dans les Yvelines et oui tout à
fait alors si vous avez envie d'avoir un
poulailler mais que vous avez peur de
sauter le pas Tanguy l'orphelin peut
vous aider il a créé l'entreprise à
chacun sa poule il y a 3 ans spécialisé
du coup dans les poules elle répond aux
besoins des particuliers et des
professionnels conseils livraison et
suivis on est allé à sa rencontre
non là il y aura pas il y aura pas de
petits parce que faut qu'elle les couvre
faut qu'elle le chauffe conseillez et
accompagner ce sont les missions que ces
données Tanguy à la tête de à chacun sa
poule une entreprise qui l'a créé il y a
3 ans ce jeune entrepreneur de 25 ans
s'est spécialisé dans les gallinacées
ouais que j'ai créé là il y a trois ans
et du coup bah le but moi c'est de
promouvoir la poule en ville quand j'ai
été petit que j'ai commencé à avoir des
poules
j'ai fait toutes les erreurs possibles
je savais pas du comment faire je me
suis dit pour éviter que les gens
fassent ces erreurs bah autant les
accompagner sur ça donc c'est bien les
conseillé sur la construction de
l'enclos le poulailler comment voilà
essayer de à la fois avoir des poules en
même temps préserver aussi un peu son
jardin ils ont souvent des questions sur
les contraintes que ça peut représenter
elle vient tous toujours on m'a attaqué
c'est vrai ah ouais tu as pas trop peur
depuis vraiment quand même 6 ans il y a
une nouvelle on va dire en tout cas en
ville voilà les gens demandent de plus
en plus à avoir des poules et un des
animaux les plus présents chez les
foyers c'est un français sur disque qui
a des poules chez soi une expertise
qu'il met au service des particuliers
comme des professionnels en 2021 Tanguy
a aidé à mettre en place et concevoir le
poulailler du parc Chanel de
Croissy-sur-Seine à la demande de la
mairie il en assure le suivi toutes les
semaines
comme ça puis après c'est récupéré les
œufs quand on a de la chance il y en a
j'ai débuté avec les particuliers et
maintenant je fais aussi des
installations dans les EHPAD les écoles
les collectivités là comme on voit à
Croatie parce que le but voilà c'est que
ceux qui n'ont pas de jardin chez eux
qui peuvent pas avoir de poule va plus
en avoir dans d'autres lieux si vous
voulez
[Musique]
un animal qui va manger nos restes
alimentaires à peu près 75 kg de déchets
organiques par an quand tu vas s'occuper
de sa poule dans son jardin pourquoi on
vient dans un parc regarder les poules
c'est un peu le temps qui s'arrête on
est vraiment avec les animaux on les
regarde on les observe Tanguy livre ses
poules issu d'un élevage du Vexin tous
les mercredis dans les Yvelines
cette semaine de poules viennent
compléter le poulailler Doremi un
particulier de Morainvilliers une
troisième les rejoindra en mai avec une
particularité c'est une poule de
réformes
à Feucherolles il y a 2500 2600 poules
qui normalement sont mises à l'abattoir
au bout de 18 mois parce que elles sont
considérées comme moins productives et
là pour la deuxième année consécutive on
décide de les distribuer aux
particuliers parce que c'est des poules
qui pondent encore quatre semaines à peu
près qui peuvent vivre encore au moins
deux ans mes parents étaient paysans mon
grand-père était paysan et j'ai donc été
élevé avec des animaux tout ce qui est
poules canards et tout ça il meurent de
la bonne de leur bonne mort ici mais je
suis content au contraire de là de
trouver et puis j'ai pris une réformée
parce qu'on en soit quand même une mai
puis de 2500 poules de réforme
rechercheront un foyer d'ici mai
prochain la poule devant moi est vendue
5 euros pour en réserver rendez-vous sur
le site internet de chacun sa poule
adopte une poule est-ce que vous aussi
Régine vous avez franchi le pas
j'ai déjà franchi le pas j'ai déjà deux
poules et comme elle mange toute ma
pelouse je vais peut-être m'arrêter là
ça vous a donné envie vous peut-être
d'adopter une poule en faisant ce
reportage alors j'aimerais beaucoup mais
j'ai la SPA de jardin donc je peux pas
les accueillir bon en tout cas merci
pour cette découverte c'est bientôt la
fin de cette émission juste avant de
vous quitter on va jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil à vos prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
ce sera toujours frais demain matin dans
les Yvelines mais avec tout de même du
soleil annoncé sur l'ensemble du
département il devrait faire 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et dans les secteurs de
Versailles et 50 ans en Yvelines 6
degrés à Houdan et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi les conditions météo se
dégradent avec de la pluie prévue dans
le département seul le secteur de
Versailles 50 ans en est venu pour être
épargné côté température comptait entre
10 et 12 degrés voilà c'est la fin de ce
7 8 une émission depuis le vélo de Rome
national de 50 ans en Yvelines à
l'occasion de skit le rendez-vous dédié
aux innovations et aux talents du
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines un
événement à suivre également sur nos
réseaux sociaux merci de votre fidélité
merci également aux équipes techniques
qui sont sur le pont depuis plusieurs
jours pour vous assurer ces émissions Le
7 8 reprendra demain ici même ces
quartiers pour une nouvelle émission à
l'occasion toujours du ski heat belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]